Hello, Dr. Kevin Conner here, and we understand that when you're diagnosed with something as serious as cancer, it is very scary.
Sometimes it's really hard to slow down and think about what to do, and that's what we're trying to encourage people to do.
Obviously, if you're listening to this video, you're looking for alternative things, and we just want to encourage you to better what your type of cancer,
even if it's not listed on here, from a natural perspective, it's not so much the diagnosis, the type of cancer.
It is what we're going to do about changing the balloon, changing the environment that the cancer started in, and that's the key.
Whether you choose to do standards of care, always understand that you can add alternative care to it.
That's a big question that we get with a lot of people is that they think they have to choose between one or the other, and that's just not true.
Many of our patients are doing chemotherapy, along with what we're doing, or they've exhausted chemotherapy and surgery and radiation.
Now they're looking for alternative care. I kind of wish they would have started it together right away.
They would have had a better outcome, I always think that.
Because with alternative care, we're building up your immune system, we're building up your healthy cells so that you can best fight this off, and deal with the side effects of conventional care at the same time.
But many times would you make the decision to go alternative as well, you're confused, because what supplements should I take?
I'm going to say, what's your my diet be? We kind of get bombarded by well-meaning people that say, hey, take this, and take this, or my sister's friend did well with this, and it gets confusing.
And we certainly don't want you taking a ton of different things. My book has a list of probably 100 different known and researched natural cancer killers, but we don't want you taking all those or even the portion of those.
We want to get down to three or four things that are going to be best for you. The only way we know that is by testing, that's what we do.
We test for that, we test for diet, we test for what nutrition to take, what frequencies to use.
Ultimately, we want the best outcome for you, and in doing so, we understand that we offer all our stuff on our website, our books, everything as a free download.
We want you to enjoy those, learn from those, and understand also that regardless of whether you choose us for your care or not, that we're going to be praying for you.
And we believe that's your most important tool.